wir haben verstärkung bekommen bei uns
im studio zu besuch bei uns der spd
experte für flüchtlingspolitik lars
castellucci paris schönen guten tag herr
castellucci einmal ganz persönlich wenn
sie diese bilder der vergangenen tage
der vergangenen stunden dort sehen aus
dem grenzgebiet
was gehen in ihnen für gefühle um haben
sie sorge vor dem was auf ihn zukommen
könnte tausende die nach deutschland
wollen oder haben sie mitgefühl vor
allen dingen mitleid mit all denen die
dort in der kälte sitzen am zaun stehen
frieren und sich gedanken machen um ihre
ganz persönliche zukunft ja ist ja kein
gegensatz was ihr gerade schildern also
einmalig war unter anderem auf lesbos
als ich dort das lager besucht habe ging
es mir auch nicht gut das sind immer
schlimme bilder und ich finde politiker
müssen sich vom elend in der welt
berühren lassen sonst braucht man sie
nicht sonst werden sie nicht tätig
werden und das geht mir bei der personen
die bei mir im wahlkreisbüro in
schicksal hat genauso wie wenn man jetzt
solche fernsehbilder bekommt ist das
eine aber ich bin auch zuversichtlich
denn wir haben in den letzten jahren ja
auch vieles erlebt und auch lösungen
erarbeitet und deswegen werden wir auch
diese krise meistern werden weiß dann
denn es handelt sich ja im kern nicht um
der migrationsfrage hier sondern es ist
hier ein verbrecher unterwegs der
menschen an diese grenze verbringt und
ich denke darüber sollten wir jetzt auch
sprechen nach meistern sieht es aber im
moment nicht aus in der vorletzten nacht
wurde der grenzzaun durchschnitten
immer wieder sehen wir auch bilder von
menschen die dort ausharren die leute
frieren die zu einem jahr spielball
geworden sind was ist ihre lösung
schlagen sie vor also das ist zunächst
mal ein abscheuliches verbrechen dieses
diktators lukaschenko ich nenne das
staatlichen menschenhandel das ist
leider eine kategorie die wir noch nicht
rechtlich gefasst haben wir sind damit
von erdogan schon mal konfrontiert
worden und jetzt lernen wir dass auch in
belarus vernascht werden davon
überrascht wir werden uns wir dürfen uns
als solche sachen nicht gewöhnen sondern
wir müssen dafür sowie für andere
angriffe auch uns wappnen müssen wir uns
rüsten und müssen wir auch die
rechtlichen vorkehrungen treffen ich bin
dafür dass man jemanden wie lukaschenko
für soetwas anzeigen und vor ein gericht
stellen kann weil das ist eine ganz ganz
schwierige art der bedrohung die hier
auf dem rücken von ganz armen menschen
stattfindet und deswegen ist unsere
erste aufgabe das auch zu unterbrechen
und weil sie sagen dass es jetzt zu
wenig passiert passiert meistens zu
wenig wenn wir irgendwo eingeladen sind
und das kann man auch nur zu gestehen
aber wir werden jetzt ein auf alle
partnerländer auf die länder von denen
die menschen
losziehen auf die fluggesellschaften und
wir haben dabei auch schon erste erfolge
dass diese linien unterbrochen werden
noch mal es geht hier einerseits um das
schicksal der menschen die vor ort sind
da geht es um humanität und da müssen
wir auch tätig werden da muss auch polen
uns unterstützen aber vor allem geht es
darum diesen zustrom zu stoppen ganz
kurz was sind die erfolge weil sie sie
gerade nennen das heißt es geht weniger
flüge definitiv in den vergangenen
stunden nach minsk und moskau also dass
hier besteht also wir haben hier
weiterhin eine zahl von vielleicht knapp
1000 die tägliche in belarus ankommen
allerdings sind wir ja nicht vor ort
dort und können durch zell deswegen kann
ich ihnen das jetzt nicht im detail
bestätigen aber ich weiß dass wir
beispielsweise mit der irakischen
regierung oder mit der jordanischen
regierung schon erfolgreich sind und
dort auch begonnen wird diese flüge zu
unterbinden
man hat überhaupt gar nichts von olaf
scholz wie erklären sie sich das ja ist
ja womöglich bald kanzler er ist auf
jeden fall vizekanzler heute wird er
sprechen es geht aber vermutlich um
corona sollte er sich nicht zu wort
melden in dieser krise also olaf scholz
wird jetzt gerade diesen minuten sein
sakko wahrscheinlich zu machen und vorne
hin ans rednerpult sich langsam auf
machen wenn so ein corona geht das ist
auch wichtig die menschen haben verdient
dass es hier orientierung gibt aber es
gehört sich auch dazu diese themen ins
deutsche parlament auch wieder stärker
zu bringen und deutlich zu machen dass
wir hier diese regelungen auch treffen
und auch die verantwortung dafür
übernehmen dass wird heute stattfinden
und gleich im anschluss wird es eine
debatte geben im deutschen bundestag
über der wirt der bundesaußenminister
alkomat sprechen ich denke das ist auch
eine gute arbeitsteilung also sie
erwarten von olaf scholz nicht dass
assad oder erwarten sie dass hetze
diesem thema das nicht nur zugucken ich
denke dass heute für ihn das thema
corona ist und dass wir dann eine
debatte haben in der der außenminister
die richtigen worte finden aber das ist
die reaktion von olaf scholz in den
vergangenen tagen auch wir hatten ihm
ihr angefragt schon vorgestern da sagte
er heute nicht also heute an diesem
donnerstag einen tag später ist dann
auch wieder heute nicht das problem ist
sie haben es hier mit einem haben sie ja
selber gesagt habe mit einem diktator zu
tun der spart nicht an klaren worten der
setzt uns ordentlich unter druck der
schick die flüchtlinge sofort an die
grenze und legt dann verbal noch mal
nach seine soldaten stehen an der grenze
ihm gegenüber polnische soldaten in der
nacht waren schüsse und wir haben keine
regierung und das gefühl ist man ist
hilflos im moment da äußert sich noch
nicht jemand klar und olaf scholz eben
auch nicht warum heute nicht
also ich freue mich über ihr interesse
an olaf scholz und hoffe auch dass das
über sehr viele jahre jetzt nicht
abreißen wird aber wir haben ja schon
bei der letzten regierungsbildung
gesehen dass es sehr lange gedauert hat
und da sind auch leute auf mich
zugekommen hört ja der regierung an er
sehr viel zu tun ziel ist vergisst er
darauf dass 90 hin gerade bestätigen was
sie gerade sagen wir haben schon vor
vier jahren haben wir eine sehr sehr
lange phase der regierungsbildung gehabt
und die menschen sind auch etwas unruhig
gewesen ja gefehlt da nicht irgendwas
funktioniert da eigentlich alles und wir
haben gesehen wir sind über diese zeit
gut rübergekommen ja es ist eine
besondere zeit man kann jetzt auch nicht
wir haben parallel laufende
verhandlungen und wir müssen sehen dass
das alles gut orchestriert wird aber
genau daran wird ja auch gearbeitet und
wenn wir jetzt sehen dass wir jetzt
mitte november haben und hoffentlich in
der ersten dezemberhälfte dann den
kanzler wählen dann haben wir das ja
auch geschafft aber noch einmal um das
auf den punkt zu bringen er sagt ja
gerade nichts offenbar das haben sie ja
gerade bestätigt mit ihren worten weil
er diese verhandlung ordentlich
orchestrieren möchte sagen sie das heißt
der würde im moment riskieren mit klaren
worten richtung lukas schenk und putin
dass ihnen die ampel möglicherweise ja
irgendwie aus dem außen
aus dem aus dem griff gerät das er dass
da nicht zusammen gebunden bekommt ihm
ist im moment die ampel wichtiger als
dann klare worte zu schicken nach minsk
und nach moskau also ich teile ihre
kritik mich auf möglicherweise werden
wir uns da auch nicht einigen ich bin
der auffassung dass ist an klaren worten
an die adresse von herrn lukaschenko in
keiner weise fehlt wir haben eine
amtierende bundesregierung die auch
weiter geschäftsführend im amt ist die
macht ihre arbeit und parallel stehen
beispielsweise ich ihnen jetzt hier auch
zur verfügung die schau mal rein olaf
scholz hat nämlich was gesagt das war
aber im august 2020 da hat er mit der
gesprochen und da ging es um lukaschenko
wäscherei ich bin fest davon überzeugt
dass dieser präsident keine legitimation
mehr hat sonst würde nicht mit so
unglaublicher so brutaler gewalt agieren
und die tatsache dass sich überhaupt
niemand gegenwärtig einschüchtern lässt
dass viele menschen sehr viel riskieren
ist ja auch eine große hoffnung der
demokratie denn letztendlich ist die
demokratie ja etwas das aus dem volk
wächst und auf der kraft des volkes
beruht und das zeigt sich hier ja diese
hoffnung wurde zerschlagen damals was
man sagen lukas schinko dennoch an der
macht an der macht geblieben wir
erinnern uns alle aus an diese bilder
die wir damals aus belarus gesehen haben
wie schon sie jetzt dort in die zukunft
was muss passieren dort am zaun werde
darüber gesprochen immer wieder hören
wir sanktionen es wird fast
überparteilich das gleiche gefordert
aber um die frage was passiert mit den
menschen die dort jetzt in diesen
minuten wenn wir sprechen frieren und
rüber wollen sondern sie rein oder
sollen sie in den wäldern also erstmal
klare kante gegenüber dem regime
sanktionen mcenroe erspüren und diese
dinge haben wir die situation vor ort
und wir haben klare grundsätze an den
europäischen außengrenzen soll niemand
zu tode kommen wäre es dorthin schafft
der soll anständig behandelt werden da
muss die menschenwürde gelten und die
gesetze und die rente das recht dass wir
eben auch geschaffen haben wir sind dem
siebzigsten jahr der genfer
flüchtlingskonvention die ist sehr
bedroht und so unser anliegen ist es
dass wir sie auch erhalten können auch
in zukunft also an dieser grenze muss
recht und ordnung gelten das heißt dass
die das grenzmanagement auch
funktionieren muss das gilt übrigens für
beide seiten weder haben migranten ein
recht mit weiß sangen sich versuchen
selber im weg durch zu schaffen aber
umgekehrt sind puts becks illegal
deswegen bin ich dafür und tritt der spd
fraktion dafür ein dass frontex tor zum
einsatz kommt und eine an
menschenrechten orientierte
grenzpolitik
das funktioniert nicht frontex ist die
menschen sind aber die frage ganz
konkret die menschen die dort jetzt sind
reinholen in die eu oder nicht also
zunächst mal geht es um humanitäre hilfe
vor ort also da muss der zugang
gewährleistet zahlen die verletzt heißt
es decken über den zaun werfen oder das
heißt dass dort die hilfsorganisationen
zugang finden müssen und sie kennen das
ja an anderen orten auch das dann
stabile unterkünfte stattfinden dass die
menschen erst versorgt werden was
ernährung was mit aufs politische gebiet
das heißt man müsste lukas zustimmen an
der stelle wo sie sind muss hilfe
zugänglich sein das ist der erste punkt
und dann ist klar dass wir darüber
sprechen dass das natürlich kein
dauerzustand ist und dann wird es das
geben was wir rechtlich noch mal es geht
um recht und ordnung und das auch
durchzusetzen ist völlig klar wenn
jemand an den grenzen auftaucht an den
europäischen außengrenzen und um
aufnahme um schutz nach sucht dann gehen
verfahren los dann geht übrigens auch
los das wir registrieren müssen dass er
wissen müssen um wen handelt er sich
denn da eigentlich dann ist eine
sicherheitsüberprüfung nötig und wenn es
ein asylverfahren geben soll weil die
leute danach fragen dann muss das auch
stattfinden das sind die dinge die vor
uns liegen und am ende wird es auch um
verteilung gehen in länder die dazu
bereit sind aber im moment ist es
tatsächlich die aufgabe unmittelbar
humanitäre hilfe dort auch ankommen zu
lassen und da sind wir dabei alle
möglichen druck und gespräche zu führen
dass das auch stattfinden kann noch
einmal ein letztes mal ganz konkret die
frage weil all die fragen und antworten
die sie gegeben haben die sind
unzweifelhaft wichtig und trotzdem lösen
sie vor ort gerade das aktuelle problem
nicht die wirken möglicherweise
langfristig aber konkret am zaun dort
die tausenden die dastehen sind sie froh
um jeden der reinkommt oder froh um
jeden der am zaun stehen bleibt auf der
nicht eu seite vor zu sein ist jetzt
hier keine kategorie sind ich habe
gesagt wir haben rechte und wir haben
gesetze und die haben überall zu gelten
für leute die ihr im land leben und ihr
normales leben nachgehen und arbeiten
und das gilt auch wenn jemand an einer
grenze kommt gibt es keine
privatangelegenheit da einfach drüber zu
kommen sondern es gibt regeln die
geschaffen worden sind nachdem das
stattzufinden hat das geht im moment
nicht weil die polnische regierung mit
der mit polizei und militär dort
aufgetreten ist und die menschen
überhaupt keinen zugang zu verfahren
haben und wir unser ansatz ist dass ich
dass es schnellstmöglich ändern muss sie
bauen gibt es hier im sehr starken druck
auf das ist schnell gehen muss das ist
genau das was ich wenn ich in gremien
sitze auch mache sie haben vorhin auch
gesagt der lukaschenkos 800 bleibt in
unsere reaktion aber es ist für politik
auch ganz wichtig sich nicht treiben zu
lassen und immer nur an getrieben zu
sein sondern konsequent bei den dingen
zu sein die wir als lösungen gefunden
haben und denen nach und nach immer
besser zur durchsetzung zu verhelfen und
da sind wir dran und manchmal auch
schnell reagieren ich finde auch das
haben die letzten monate gezeigt und ich
glaube das sehen wir jetzt besonders
auch bei dieser krise da glaube ich kann
man sich nicht nur auf das verlassen was
man für ein regelwerk geschaffen hat man
steht vor einer neuen situation